one of the joys of watching hamilton at
home is having the chance to discover
little moments of genius hidden away in
the musical
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm going to reveal how one small
character plays a big part in tying the
whole show together and highlights the
musical's major themes
just before we begin i want to thank the
sponsor of this video
squarespace more on why they're a great
place to build a website at the end
one of the ensemble characters known as
the bullet plays a secret role in
foreshadowing alexander hamilton's
ultimate fate and she also heralds doom
for many of the other characters she
interacts with
the bullet's first significant moment
that highlights her association with
mortality comes at the end of king
george's song you'll be back
here she appears as a spy who ends up
being killed by a british soldier
and an interesting detail to note is
that alexander hamilton is there
watching in the background when it
happens but the bullet's earliest
interaction with hamilton actually
happens in the show's first song now to
understand her significance we need to
look at both how she moves
and when because the majority of the
musical is tightly choreographed with
each dancer's moves tied to specific
lyrics
and as choreographer andy blankenbueller
has said every movement on stage
furthers the story in some way so it's
intriguing that after bear raps about
hamilton planning for the future
hamilton passes a book to the bullet a
hint shall play
an important role in his future then for
a split second the whole ensemble point
a finger towards the sky
in a move that's repeated throughout the
show and is reminiscent of hamilton with
his gun at the end
the bullet also pops up significantly
during stay alive where she carries a
bullet fired by a red coat towards
hamilton
this time the bullet just misses him
though it's a sinister nod to hamilton's
doomed encounter with her during the
show's final jewel
where aaron burr's shot hits its target
in the song yorktown the bullet teams up
with john laurens to kill a redcoat
after which they congratulate each other
with a handshake unfortunately for
lawrence his interaction with the bullet
signals his downfall
and shortly before the end of the first
act hamilton receives news that his
friend died at a gunfight with
retreating british soldiers
interestingly yorktown isn't the first
time the bullet takes notice of laurens
though
she actually already had her eye on him
back during the show's second song aaron
bursa
when she stood watching him rap i'm john
laurens in the place to be
after which she took a seat at the table
behind him as he rapped about how he was
going to take down the red coats
in act two the bullet's connection to
death and demise grows even stronger as
she begins to speak directly to the main
characters
sometimes guiding them towards their
fate in the song blow us all away
the bullet tells philip hamilton where
he can find george ike
who publicly disparaged his father
alexander during a fourth of july speech
that leads to phillips ill-fated jewel
with ike who ends up mortally wounding
him
there's a couple of intriguing things to
note about this scene fittingly just
before
philip is shot the bullet walks directly
behind him
and it's also a neat little irony that
as philip flirts with the woman early on
in the scene he's unwittingly flirting
with death
the bullet also sets in motion the
events that lead burr to his deadly
confrontation with hamilton
during the election of 1800 she chimes
in with those supporting burr
i like that i can't believe we're here
with him
burr is convinced he will win but when
hamilton opposes him to support
jefferson instead
buzz election chances are dashed setting
him on the path to finally confront
hamilton
and in your obedient servant not only
does the bullet carry burr's desk
on stage but she also gives him the
quill he uses to write the letters to
hamilton that end in their deadly jewel
the bullet completes her arc by bringing
death to the musical's protagonist when
she appears just as
fires his gun during his final face-off
with hamilton as hamilton begins his
soliloquy she gradually edges towards
him
however the ensemble prevent her from
fully reaching him
still as they lift her up and hamilton
revolves around the stage
she keeps the bullet pointed at him
signaling that although the moment is
being temporarily delayed
he cannot avoid his fate or as ariana
debose who plays the bullet has said
you can look at the final jewel in a
couple of different ways we're slowing
the bullet down to give hamilton time to
say everything he wants to say
or we're saying this is it it's
inevitable it's happening
so you can stare it right in the face
curiously the bullet is pulled away as
eliza enters the scene
perhaps a nod to the fact that eliza
keeps hamilton figuratively alive
by doing everything she can to preserve
his legacy after he dies
this fits nicely with the musical's
major themes in other words it's
meditation on death and what's left
behind that is
legacy what if this bullet is my legacy
legacy
indeed the whole show is like a two and
a half hour memento mori a reminder of
the inevitability of death
and transience of life something
hamilton was obsessed with as miranda
said of himself and hamilton the ticking
clock of mortality
is loud in both our ears and it sets us
to work
there are also several other important
bullet moments worth looking out for in
the show
when the ensemble form a line beside
hamilton during 10 jewel commandments
ominously the bullet is right next to
him when they sing the line
pick a place to die
[Music]
she then turns to face him and dances
alongside him as the song continues with
several more ominous lines
including leave a note for your next of
kin pray that hell or heaven lets you in
leave a note for you next to king tell
him where you've been
pray that hell of heaven let's you're in
and fittingly she's also dancing close
by him when he sings the ninth rule
look him in the eye aim no higher which
foreshadows the plot perfectly because
hamilton ignores that rule twice and
each time it ends in death
first his sons and then his own the fact
characters are constantly dancing around
with death in the show
makes me think she fits within the
medieval concept of the dance macabre
aka the dance of death which was a
reminder of the power and universality
of death
the connection between the bullet and
hamilton during this song
takes on even more meaning as it's yet
another way that the ten jewel
commandment
sets up the show's climactic combat
between hamilton and burr
which it also does by having them act as
seconds for laurens and lee during this
earlier duel
thus creating a parallel between the two
moments
the bullet's interaction with king
george is also interesting because she's
the one who tells him about john adams
becoming the next
president what john adams
and with adam's rise to power comes the
decline of hamilton's political
reputation and career
fires hamilton hamilton publishes his
response
sit down john you fat mother much
earlier in the musical
while hamilton is musing over when his
death will come in the song my shot
significantly the bullet is the last of
the ensemble to unfreeze
we wrote like moses claiming i promised
land ariana dubose who plays the bullet
has said about her role that it's really
intense for me
because i always know i'm aiming for him
even if the rest of the ensemble members
don't
so even if i'm just a lady in a ball
gown at a party there's still a part of
my character that knows that that moment
is going to come
the genius of the bullet is that
although hamilton frets over his legacy
and when he'll die
both he and we don't fully take in the
subtle ways the bullet has been
foreshadowing his fate until the very
end when of course
everyone sees her clearly and if you
feel inspired by the genius of hamilton
then why not give an outlet to your own
creativity on squarespace
a fantastic online platform that you can
easily use to build your own website
they have ready-made designer templates
that you can quickly customize to create
your own blog podcast or online store
you don't need any technical knowledge
and they offer amazing 24 7 support for
any questions or help you might need
squarespace also integrates smoothly
with your social accounts letting you
auto post to twitter facebook and tumblr
so head on over to squarespace.comflix
or follow the link in the video
description below where you can try the
platform completely free for 14 days
and when your site is ready to launch
you'll get an extra 10
discount with that link so what other
characters or moments do you most
appreciate in hamilton
let me know in the comments below by the
way a big shout out to everyone who
mentioned the bullet and requested this
video on my previous hamilton videos
and if you enjoyed this don't forget to
subscribe and leave a thumbs up
to learn more about all the other
amazing details in the musical and how
the show changed history
tap left for my full hamilton playlist
or tap write for something else you're
sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee guy movie lovers